blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman welcome everybody i uh i i
wish i could come to you today and say
good people of my audience remember that
little coved blip last week i told you
about that little ten percent pop in
cases it was nothing cases are back down
i wish i could tell you that and i could
but i would be lying and i make every
effort not to lie to you on this program
because cases are back up again
and cases are now back up in the united
states cases are up even more globally
and we don't know
the trajectory here there are models
saying this is the beginning of another
disaster
there are models saying there will be a
brief spike into sort of january and
then it's going to be a big big big
decline the permanent decline the final
decline
um quite frankly there have been models
indicating everything for almost two
years now and some of them
happen to come across the correct
explanation but there is very little
consistency in which models those are so
i think we do not know the direction
that this is going and of course the
situation is dynamic in the sense that
where it goes will depend on what we do
but let's look at where the numbers are
today in the united states dating back
to the end of october
cases have climbed
16
from 71 000 cases a day to 83 000 cases
a day now we've been dancing here
between 60 and 100 000 cases a day for a
very long time
to really get this to the point where
we would consider it based on public
health expert assessments
epidemiologists etc
really get this under control
10 000 cases a day is the number that is
being discussed it has been a really
long time since we were even remotely
close to that
as uh as if the u.s numbers aren't bad
enough
globally cases have climbed even more 22
percent
from their bottom of about 400 000
coveted cases a day in the middle of
october
now up 22
to close to 500 000 cases a day globally
half a million coveted cases that we
know about globally and we know we're
not capturing nearly every coveted case
with a positive test now if there's any
okay news so far
it's that again
for now in the us
deaths are still not ticking up
along with the cases however
you've probably heard me say this a
hundred times now it often takes three
to four weeks for deaths to follow what
cases do
so we have to look out for that but for
now
deaths continuing down they peak during
delta around 2000 a day
they're now down to less than half of
that under a thousand deaths a day
that's a very good thing however if we
look at the global trend where the case
spike started about two weeks before it
started in the us
deaths are increasing just a bit up
about five six percent so it's not a
disaster yet globally in terms of the
death increase
we do need to wait two to three more
weeks to see if the death increase is
going to follow here in the united
states what's the hope
the hope is
we have enough vaccination combined with
recovered immunity
that cases and deaths start to become
decoupled we've talked about this before
if everyone is vaccinated a case
means a lot less in terms of how likely
it is to lead to a hospitalization and
subsequently leave to a death
the hope would be
we are
vaccinated enough we have enough
immunity
that cases will go up without deaths
going up
it's really not apparent that that's the
case right now 58.8 percent of the
country is fully vaccinated call it 59
percent you then have to add to that
people with some level of immunity
despite being unvaccinated because
they've recovered from covid we know
that can be hard to predict how long
does that last how robust is it but
officially there have been 48 million
cases in the u.s now you can't just say
add 48 million why well a lot of those
48 million people have been vaccinated
so they're actually in both groups at
the same time some of the people that
have recovered have immunity that may
have waned completely by now at the same
time there are people who don't even
show up in the number of 48 million u.s
cases
at all because they never got a test but
they have some immunity so we just don't
know what number to add let's imagine
that to the 58
that are vaccinated we can add 40
million total that's like 12 of the u.s
so maybe
right now
we're at 70 of the population 72 percent
of the population with some immunity
today
that may not be enough
to decouple
cases and deaths
but maybe we're starting to get close it
does seem in the midst of all this that
third doses are coming for everybody
there's a report from axios that the
biden administration is expected to
start
the booster expansion process to
authorize third doses to all adults
potentially as early as this week could
be today could be tomorrow could be
friday that's according to a source
familiar with the internal planning as i
told you guys on the bonus show etc
i got my third dose on thursday
um and it does seem as though third
doses are likely coming for everybody
who has been following the
recommendations on vaccination obviously
people who haven't gotten dose one or
dose two are not going to get those
three because that's just not how it
works so that's the latest as far as
covid is concerned we're going to
continue following these numbers let's
hope that next week heading into
thanksgiving we have uh something um
something that looks better oh peop
again people have been asking me what am
i doing as far as thanksgiving goes i'm
going to go to a thanksgiving gathering
where everybody will be tested on the
way in and everybody's vaccinated and
feels pretty safe to me
feels pretty safe to everybody involved
and so that is my plan i know we have a
poll
on our youtube community tab right now
that you can vote in where you could if
you are doing thanksgiving if you're in
the us
um what is the vaccination policy there
is it uh
proof required
um is it it's a request but not a
requirement is it you know whatever you
can let us know and we'll have
those results coming to you very very
soon
a former new jersey republican governor
chris christie
is uh the author of a new book it's one
of these kind of trash political books
and he was interviewed he did the media
rounds yesterday he was interviewed on
cnn he was interviewed a bunch of
different places but the most
interesting interview that chris
christie did was with nicole wallace on
msnbc i'm not some big nicole wallace
fan i think she often does interesting
interviews
and she
really made chris christie look as
stupid as the book appears to be
on the subject matter so let let me kind
of give you the back story chris
christie
former republican governor of new jersey
involved in that horrifying bridgegate
scandal where they shut down a lane of
the george washington bridge as a
political punishment
to the mayor of i don't remember what
jersey town fought something
uh over a political disagreement just a
disgusting disgusting thing christy ran
for the republican nomination in 2016
slammed donald trump really really hard
and then eventually fell in line and was
famously pictured uh standing behind
trump looking ill like he had some bad
clams as he was now
endorsing trump and trump behaving as
trump always does in completely
embarrassing fashion and chris christie
looking ill and then he has tried to
kind of frame himself as okay i did
support trump but then i also have
concerns about
trying to play every side of the
republican party so now chris christie
writes this book he's going to tell the
republican party how to save itself the
book is called republican rescue
saving the party from truth deniers
conspiracy theorists
and the dangerous policies of joe biden
well the republican party needs to be
rescued from trump it's really not about
joe biden at all and i apologize i just
punched my microphone there so
it's just one of these garbage books
enough with all the infighting the truth
denying the wild conspiracy claims the
looking backward the refusal to focus on
the dangerous biden agenda here's chris
christie's urgent guide for recapturing
republican glory what and winning
elections again
told with the new jersey frankness and
news breaking insights that made the
two-term two-term governor trump early
endorser and presidential candidate an
indispensable voice it it's just
completely bonkers and one of the things
about the book
um and you can look at the
um
i wanted to pull up the table of
contents for you guys but i'm unable to
right now um one of the things about the
book is it sort of seems to miss number
one like the main source of right-wing
conspiracies which is right-wing media
including fox news and these other
networks he talks about cnn he talks
about you know all these other
news networks doesn't talk about fox
news and good for her nicole wallace
calls him out and it's painful in the
best of ways to see how just silly chris
christie looks take a look at this you
know the book is called um it's about
conspiracies and lies and you really
don't take on fox news why not
look because you've seen the checkered
card because because the book no i i
don't watch it but the book are you
aware of what he does not really i don't
pay a lot of attention to it republican
insider
chris christie has written a
comprehensive book
meant to guide republicans away from
conspiracy theories
and he claims not to know what tucker
carlson does now he may be lying he may
be lying because he knows exactly what
tucker does he doesn't want to answer
for it that may be possible
however how can you even claim to be an
authoritative authoritative voice on
what republicans need to do to push back
against conspiracies and lies and say i
have no idea what happens on the tucker
carlson show but with truth deniers
conspiracy theorists on the cover right
and you attack cnn and the new york
times and msnbc
but excuse me i don't attack them as
conspiracy theorists or truth deniers i
talk about bias it is more dangerous to
the country and then conspiracy
theorists
no but that's the third section of the
book where i talk about the movement
forward in the center portion of the
book we talk about the conspiracy
theories and the truth denying that went
on with things like q anon pizzagate
the election situation john birch
society and that's what i talk about
there's two sections of the book and
you're kind of missing some of the major
stuff from the right i'm sure
accidentally you're conflating that i'm
not conflating them but i don't think i
don't think it's an intellectually
honest case to make against conspiracy
theories without taking on fox news well
i could listen then you can write that
in your book well i'm not trying to
rescue the republican party i understand
he's not claiming to be the
she's that's it's such a dumb thing for
him to say well put that in your book
she's not claiming to be the
authoritative voice
about the lies and the conspiracies that
that have been told that chris christie
is whoever you whenever you want to
write yourself any questions you want to
run for president what's your
relationship with fox news well first of
all i didn't say i wanted to run for
president you said that so let's be
clear about it well a lot of people have
said that last three days you haven't
corrected anything i understand
no what i've said is that i certainly
will think about it but i won't make any
decision for at least another year do
you think that fox news in prime time is
good for the country or bad listen there
are shows that i like in fox news
writing their shows that i don't like
like there are shows that i like afraid
to question the purveyors of conspiracy
theories and by the way you're but
that's your opinion you're welcome to
your opinion like everybody else in this
country is welcome to your opinion i
don't consider people like sean hannity
or laura ingram uh purveyors i didn't
say either their names
so so
did you see what just happened
nicole wallace never mentioned uh
hannity and laura ingram chris christie
brought them up so you could say well
maybe he's got a guilty mind there but
hannity and ingram are huge hannity was
giving medical advice on his show ingram
has been on an anti-vaxx tirade for six
months so not only did nicole wallace
not bring them up chris christie's lying
about they're not perv they are
purveyors you said you said the evening
news programs at fox street eight pm
hours well and as i told you i don't
watch the show so i don't know what
tucker does from night to night
if i watch anything at night in news
because most of the time i'm watching
sports but if you're watching anything
in news i'm usually watching either sean
or laura so you may or may not support
donald trump in 2024 you may or may not
run for president and a book about liars
and conspiracy theories doesn't have
anything to say about fox news
this isn't he's this is an expert he's
written a book guys
no the book talks about you continue to
conflate it and you i don't know how you
can talk about
conspiracy theorists without talking
about fox news i was a republican i
think they've done more damage to the
party than anything i'm sure you do but
if we want to go through that i think
there are liars and conspiracy theorists
on msnbc and on cnn also so maybe i'll
write a book about all that but that's
not what this book is about
in that section of the book i'm talking
to republicans about the way i believe
we need to deal with media to be most
effective for winning
the conspiracy theorists and truth right
and he got two percent of the vote
which nobody else
on either side of the aisle is writing
about right now other than me no one
else is writing about that do you want
to solve them that's my question we've
done interviews with probably five to
ten experts on the their peop what does
that mean nobody else is writing about
it that it's it's
it's just an embarrassing interview
the proliferation of conspiracy theories
without dealing with fox news it's like
solving terrorism without dealing with
the terrorists well look that's your
opinion i disagree with your opinion and
i don't believe and i think it's
irresponsible nicole to analogize fox
news to terrorists
you're right about being a prosecutor
and of course you know
you can argue nicole wallace made a
mistake there with the analogy but it
it's act she's not saying fox news are
terrorists although you could argue that
there is stochastic terrorism being
carried out on fox news
but you could have used any analogy and
and and chris christie is able to not
deal with the substance of it by saying
you're saying fox news or like terror
it's like saying this is like dealing
with i don't know
but
it's it's it's like dealing with uh with
a flat tire uh and having no uh way to
pump it up i don't know
there's a million different ways it
could have been set her analogy is a
good one i want to understand what your
solution is to the title of the book
it's about truth deniers and conspiracy
how do we purge the truth deniers and
conspiracy theories
yeah from our party and it's by telling
the truth to our voters to our voters
where do you do that right in my book no
but where do you go where do you go buy
it go buy it on sale today you can do it
where do you do it speeches you do it in
where you're sure i did it at the reagan
library in september i did that right so
chris christie is going to solve the
problem by giving a speech at the reagan
library without mentioning what's
happening on fox news so
nice 99
nice job by nicole wallace and the the
whole thing feels very grifty and she's
right that it does seem like a pretext
to set himself up to run for president
which he that's fine that he has every
right to do that
but
if that's the idea
we would imagine he's incentivized not
to go after fox news because he'll need
fox if he ultimately wants to run for
president so there's chris christie let
me know if you're going to be reading
his book i'm all set as i like to say
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
consider yourselves invited to grab a
membership on my website joinpakman.com
we are a viewer and listener supported
program we do an extra show every day
for people who get a membership and you
can do so in mere seconds at
joinpakman.com
uh we finally found one of these
so-called dead voters from the 2020
election turns out it was a republican
voting under the name of his deceased
wife this has been one of the stories
this is one of the stories we've been
told now for a very long time but it
really scaled up with the november of
2020 election dead people are voting now
not literally dead people people who are
dead are showing up as having voted and
this is clearly some kind of major fraud
being perpetrated it's part of the theft
of the election by joe biden from donald
trump now before even analyzing and
before telling you about the story and
before analyzing the broader data around
dead people voting
it should be mentioned
that even if their claims were true of
widespread dead people voting they would
also have to show and prove
that it's happening in a way that helped
joe biden and hurt donald trump
you could have ten thousand so-called
dead people voting but if it was five
thousand dead people voting for trump
and five thousand dead people voting for
biden it doesn't actually make a
difference in the election so
absent from many of these discussions is
okay part one is is it true but part two
if true is it happening in a partisan
way where it would actually help one
candidate rather than the other the
answer to all of the above is it's not
actually happening and we're going to
get to that in a second but as is often
the case with these stories the side
shouting about the supposed fraud in
this case dead people voting is the only
side that's getting caught doing it this
is a story out of nevada
we previously mentioned this to you in a
list of examples of republicans doing
this he has now been sentenced nevada
man who voted twice using dead wife's
ballot sentenced to probation and fined
two thousand dollars this is donald kirk
hartle who has accepted a plea deal to
avoid jail time a judge on tuesday
sentenced the las vegas man to probation
on a charge he voted twice in the 2020
election by mailing in his deceased
wife's ballot
the i-team was first to report that kirk
hartl 55 years old was facing two
charges relating to last year's election
in court tuesday hartle pleaded guilty
to one charge of voting more than once
in the same election he appeared
virtually in court
he was also fined two grand as part of
the plea agreement
the original category d felony carried a
maximum prison sentence of four years
gets probation and two grand
ultimately to me this seems like a cheap
political stunt that backfired and shows
our voting system actually works because
you were ultimately caught that's what
his uh that's what the judge in the case
said
uh rosemary hartl died in 2017 at age 52
from breast cancer
kirk hardle
um his surviving husband a ballot for
rosemary was issued in october and was
received by the county but kirk said the
ballot never came to his house the
i-team found that even though rosemary
died in 2017 her name appeared on the
active voter list kirk hartle says i
would like to say i accept full
responsibility for my actions and regret
them and i'm thankful for your
consideration
so we finally found
the dead people voting
and it was a republican now this is an
opportunity to remind you first of all
there are people writing to me saying
the punishment should have been far
strict there should have been much much
stricter punishment here uh for this guy
okay that's something that can be talked
about
we have data we have done there have
been very good investigations done into
so-called dead people voting and it
turns out that it's really easy and
popular to say 10 000 people 20 000 30
000 suspected dead voters the bbc
actually investigated this uh there was
an initial claim from republicans
that for example in michigan 10 000 dead
people voted they had this list of ten
thousand people that were dead uh the
bbc did something very interesting they
said okay from the ten thousand let's
pick a random 30 let's just take 30
names at random and they started going
through the 30 names in fact they did 31
names out of the 31 they spoke to 11 of
the people
and were able to confirm they're still
alive so
random group of 31 supposedly dead
voters 11 are just straight up still
alive
they found another 17 they weren't able
to speak to them but there was no record
of their death there was no obituary
there was no record anywhere that said
these people have died
and
were able to find although they didn't
speak to them evidence
that they were alive either records or
other interactions with the public or
government system so
that got them to 28 and then they found
three people who were dead they were
dead at the time that they checked when
they looked into it the three people
were two of the three
were alive at the time that they voted
meaning they didn't do anything wrong
okay you could say well two of the
people died since sending their ballot
shouldn't be counted you could look at
that
and then one the last one
was a an error where a junior's vote was
counted as the senior imagine you know
david pakman jr although jews don't do
the junior thing imagine david pack
imagine david pakman senior is dead
david pakman jr is alive and votes and
the vote is counted wrongly as if it was
david pakman senior still only one vote
right it was counted as the wrong person
but it's still only one vote
that's what was found when bbc actually
investigated this so don't fall for the
fact that it's happening when it's not
and more importantly even if they were
able to prove that it's happening they
would also have to prove that it's
happening in a partisan way such that it
would actually help one candidate defeat
another in even a single state which
they've not recognized republican party
claims to be against cancel culture
number one
number two the republican party claims
to be a big tent party where they
welcome all this different stuff you
know different views different people
but they don't actually do that and uh
there is a very interesting new article
that the wyoming republican party is no
longer recognizing republican
congresswoman liz cheney as a republican
this is the very cancel culture that
they claim to be against look at this
the wyoming republican party voted to no
longer recognize liz cheney as a member
of the republican party the state
party's sent the state party central
committee's central committee i like
that 31 to 29 vote followed similar
votes by republican officials in roughly
one-third of wyoming's 23 counties
it's laughable to suggest liz is
anything but a committed conservative
republican said jeremy adler a cheney
spokesman
the vote marks the wyoming republican
party's second rebuke of cheney
following her vote to impeach former
president trump for his role in the
january 6 attack on the u.s capitol she
is facing a primary up for primary a
quadruple primary challenge in wyoming
but what's very interesting about this
is that very uncontroversial things get
you cancelled by the people who say
don't cancel the right says don't we
don't do cancel culture cancel culture
is bad what did liz cheney do
she voted what she believed was what was
her conscience in terms of trump's
january 6th impeachment
and she says
trump lost she's still a republican she
still voted with trump i think it was 93
percent of the time this is a committed
republican a devout republican
but saying
biden did win
biden did win
is something that can get you canceled
by the modern republican party now if
this were reversed if this was a if this
was reversed if you had
a democrat who had crossed party lines
to agree with what republicans were
saying
and democrats voted to say this is not
not a democrat anymore
fox news newsmax all the right-wing
media would do a week on
the democratic party has been hijacked
by extremists who have no tolerance for
dissenting views they cancel they do
silence from the national media on what
the wyoming republican party has done
now the truth is the republican party
actually was captured by extremists
starting in you can go back to the 80s
certainly by the time newt gingrich
became speaker of the house in 1994 it's
a cult
it's an it's the norm now in the
republican party and barry goldwater
had had i really predicted this
barry goldwater said
mark my word
if and when these preachers get control
of the republican party and they're
surely trying to do so it's going to be
a terrible damn problem frankly these
people frighten me politics and
governing demand compromise but these
christians believe they are acting in
the name of god so they can't and won't
compromise i know i've tried to deal
with them and of course barry goldwater
was right and it's been not only pastors
that have taken over the republican
party but just conservative christian
individuals in great part who want to
see a christian version of sharia law be
the ruling sort of doctrine of the
united states
and extremists of other kinds as well
goldwater predicted one piece of it but
not even really the full scope it's
actually even worse than barry goldwater
has predicted so there it is liz cheney
cancelled
by the party that is about stopping the
cancellation they claim the left is
doing we'll have more on this on our
instagram you can find that at david uh
david pakman show on instagram you can
also follow me on instagram david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right we're going to have a little
fun now my friends or we're going to cry
because it has gotten so bad and
embarrassing um you might remember what
was previously known as donald trump's
worst interview of all time colloquially
and it was when jonathan swann from
axios interviewed donald trump and trump
held up various things and said but you
can't do that about covid and it was a
crazy interview you might also remember
the other contender for trump's worst
interview of all time when he was
interviewed by chris wallace and told
chris wallace
that chris wallace wouldn't do that well
on a dementia test which was completely
off the charts we have a new interview
for you today that i submit is a top
contender for trump's most embarrassing
pathetic interview of all time this was
a much promoted interview
where the interviewer is none other
than my pillow ceo and founder mike
lindell who we sometimes know of
colloquially as mike pillow the back
story is that trump and pillow
became friends sort of at the start of
the pandemic when pillow went to the
white house and announced he'd be making
masks and he'd be making different
things instead of just pillows and this
has been a guy who has been one of the
most
off the deep end
advocates of the big lie making claims
about the supreme court is going to
reverse the election results and trump
obviously won and i've got routers and
i've got packet captures and i've got a
symposium or a symbolsium as he would
call it all these different things
cartoonish up there with sydney powell
so mike pillow scores an interview with
donald trump for some reason we don't
know
trump is wearing a tuxedo
and it's like it might just be they
agreed to do this when trump was at a
fundraiser and just walked off stage
wearing a tux and then was interviewed
we don't know it just adds to the
hilarity um and let's just jump right in
here is donald trump continuing to push
the big lie that he won in 2020 and he
says um uh oh pay in see if you pay
attention carefully you know how trump
does this thing where he says sir where
it where when he's lying
i don't even know what i'm doing sir
right when trump says sir they came to
me they said sir it's a tell that he's
making up the story there's another
example of one of these tells uh see if
you can pick it out here
we know what happened right you see it
in the reports you see it in everything
and also they're guarding they're so
guarding it they don't want to give the
votes they don't want to give the
ballots
mail-in ballots are a disaster they
basically use covet-19 or the china
virus
to rig the election and it's a shame no
and i hope the republicans get tough so
that was it when trump says and it's a
shame
it's another tell that is saying
something that's not true
uh the china virus as he calls it was
not used to rig the election and so when
he says it's a shame it's like when he
says they came to me and they said sir
he's lying mitch mcconnell's a disaster
the guy's a disaster the old crow
he should have never approved that he
should have never allowed and it was
very sad when mike pence
gave those votes over because
when mike pence didn't give any votes
over mike pence had nothing mike pence
couldn't give the election to trump it
wasn't up to pence who becomes the next
president more votes than you have
voters
when you have other things that are so
wrong and that was then
now since then many other things have
happened
which showed that you were right and i
was right and people were right that
we're looking at it right it's a very uh
yep so there is a sort of um uh
self-congratulatory announcement from
donald trump that he was right and
pillow was right then in the next moment
donald trump tells mike pillow we don't
have freedom of the press anymore in
this country and that will soon lead to
communism we don't have freedom for the
press anymore
and you're absolutely right that's the
first step toward communism
so
um listen guys if we didn't have freedom
of the press
mike pillow would not have been allowed
to do half the things he's been allowed
to do on various media networks over the
last six to 12 months that's if there's
any proof that we have freedom of the
press
it's mike lindell's media presence over
the last six to 12 months trump then
talks about this is his sort of like
pity me routine where trump mentions all
the money he lost being president of the
united states
i expected to lose a lot of money right
i lost billions i expected that i was
okay right yeah now
that appears to be a lie in a couple of
different ways
it is true
that during the course of trump's
presidency
his supposed personal net worth declined
but why is that it's because trump was
lying about his net worth for a very
very long time we discovered while trump
was president that he was less wealthy
than he claimed to be and indeed he also
dropped off the forbes richest 400 list
and all of this different stuff but
remember that donald trump made 1.6
billion dollars during his presidency an
average of 400 million dollars per year
uh and he wants us to believe that he he
did a great public service he was
willing to lose billions in order to be
president of the united states trump of
course no trump interview now is
complete what are the what what has to
be in any trump interview he refers to
someone calling him sir he tells a lie
and says that it's a shame he claims
that he won the 2020 election uh uses
the term china virus and of course of
course complains about being banned from
social media how are you feeling then i
mean is it was it like a
disbelief for was it i know so i had
hundreds of millions of people too we
had a tremendous whether it was twitter
or uh it was instagram facebook i had
you know
just
massive numbers of people and all of a
sudden
one day you wake up and you don't have
that voice anymore
he woke up and it was gone it was just
gone he didn't have it anymore um then
this is maybe the most delusional part
of the actually no
mike pillow at the end of the interview
is even worse than this and we'll get to
that but this is maybe the most
delusional part of the interview
trump starts talking about specific
states again he talks about arizona and
he's like we need
one big one and two smalls or we might
be able to do it with just two bigs he's
talking about the states he needs to win
it's almost december of 2021.
this election was almost 13 months ago
he's still talking about the math
that'll get them to to a win
in last year's election you've said
that's you know fix 2021 well i think
it's important that they know what
happened in 2020 and once you know what
happened they have a decision to make
look i think enough people know what
happened you look at arizona we don't
need all those things we need two big
ones and three small ones i guess
separately you can have two big ones or
you can have three small ones something
like that but
we know what happened right yeah you see
it in the reports you see it in
everything and also they're guarding
they're so guarding it they don't want
to give the votes they don't want to
give the ballots
mail-in ballots are a disaster they
basically use trump voted by mail
remember covet 19 or the china virus
to rig the election and it's a shame
okay so now we get into what we listened
to before so he's still talking micro
like listen pillow if we get
georgia
and arizona and pennsylvania this thing
is over
uh sir joe biden's been president for
almost a year what what are you talking
about no no no no with two big states
and three small ones and we're right
back in the white house mike i'm telling
you in insane
and then now let me get to
maybe
the craziest moment of the interview
interviewer mike lindell from my pillow
is almost in tears over how great of a
president trump was now remember as
idiotic and pathetic as we believe this
to be
there are tons of trump supporters that
also tear up when they
reminisce about the great presidency of
trump look at this that's the way god
intended it because everything that you
did
to show us what great leadership should
be right and what it can manifest
through to help all people whoever alive
and to have a great life in this country
the best country in the world and i want
to thank you as millions do for being
the greatest president we've ever had
thank you and uh we appreciate you it's
really an honor and the good news is
we're going to look back at what they
did and we're going to say they did a
terrible job
so they won't be able to talk right
because the job they've done is record
setting bad
and we're going to take back our
contracts thank you mike god bless you
thank you very much thank you god
bless uh god bless
the united sheish um what a bizarre
bizarre interview and it's all you watch
it and you're like nothing could top the
things trump is saying while sitting
strangely while wearing the tuxedo
and then pillows almost in tears over
what he believes to have been the
greatest president in the history of the
united states you
saturday night live is out of business
folks saturday night live is out of
business
while we are doing the mic pillow arc i
do want to just briefly i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on this but i do
want to briefly follow up on on
something
um there's a new deadline for mike
pillow
mike pillow says that finally praise
jesus the trump fraud case will be filed
i guess on november 23rd now that's uh i
guess the day before a day or two before
next week's thanksgiving holiday in the
united states
as a refresher if you forgot
blocked it out which i would understand
haven't been paying attention
my pillow ceo mike lindell
has been predicting trump's
reinstatement for a very long time first
it was going to be december of 2021
where the the win would be given to
trump then it was going to be by january
6th we know how that turned out then it
was going to be by the day of joe
biden's inauguration in later january
by march april trump was going to be
back the supreme court was going to take
a case mike pillow seems not to know
that cases get appealed to the supreme
court
he seems to be in the mindset that
i guess judge kavanaugh might be like
bring me the case bring i'm taking a bri
just bring a case to me
um then it was going to be trump would
be back in office by the end of august
that's two months ago three months ago
at this point the new deadline
is that some kind of mysterious legal
team
and
unclear internal research
combined with
i don't even know what else
is going to lead to an ahead of schedule
case
presumably in the supreme court
mike pillow doesn't say what's the legal
mechanism that would allow the supreme
court to just take action on
random claims of election fraud
none of it makes any sense
but here is mike pillow at
reawaken america from american faith
another one of these religious events
take a listen to this
so so that's getting that's getting
filed a week from tuesday
it's this thick it's different it's not
what was filed before okay so there's a
new thing
extremely thick maybe wide i don't know
it's gonna be filed it's different and
then i guess the supreme court
takes it up and by the way you see one
guy right behind pillow raising his fist
in
adulation and and glee and stuff like
that do you think people even believe
pillow when he says this stuff like when
they cheer and they go
do they even believe it and it's just
comedy at this point in time
it's it it is it is just worthless
substantively it's just comedy my
curiosity is
at what point
does pillow actually just say it's not
going to happen we just got to re-elect
them in 2024. what how how smooth will
that transition be let me know what you
think we'll take a quick break and be
back with more stories right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show you know something that the
american right wing
does a lot
they project and i don't mean they
project movies onto the side of a
building i'm not talking about a literal
projector here what i mean is
they accuse the left of the doing that
which they themselves actually do
and there are so many different areas in
which we could talk about this but one
of those areas recently has really
scaled up a lot to include claims that
the left is brainwashing children into
their own dogmas
often through critical race theory or
through college which is many believe is
liberal indoctrination or in other ways
they're going after the kids
it turns out that it's actually the
right that is doing this and a viewer
sent me a link to some
toe-curling trump propaganda aimed at
kids
with former arkansas republican governor
mike huckabee involved as well you have
to see this because this is them doing
what they accuse the left of doing
this is something called
the kid's guide
to president trump
and if you go to the website
which i i mean i guess we'll link to it
i don't know it's not like we're not
promoting it but you should be able to
look at this for yourselves there's a
picture of mike huckabee
and it's promoted as help your kids
learn the truth about president trump
and celebrate america
with this free patriotic gift bundle
mike huckabee co-founder of the kids
guide and one of the products is called
the kids guide to donald trump it has
drawings of trump
swearing in uh his own swearing his oath
of office with his hand on a bible being
held by abraham lincoln if you want to
look at some propaganda
and here's everything you get with this
bundle
you get the kids guide to president
trump
you get to learn our learn our histories
great again restoring faith in america
streaming video and it's like a run-on
sentence it's just crazy and then you
also get the ever bright kids magazine
which is more right-wing trash bundled
uh for uh for children this free gift
bundle will look at the language help
your kids learn
all about trump's greatest
accomplishments during his first term
first term i like that
give your kids a sneak peek inside the
trump presidency and look at look at the
description here and i'll zoom in on it
for you
the mainstream media has been no friend
to president trump they market this as
like history material the mainstream
media has been no friend to president
trump and they'll never admit that he
did a great job leading our country and
making the changes america needs give us
a list of those changes but as future
voters our children and grandchildren
deserve to understand the truth about
trump and what made him a great
president
this is what they say the left is doing
you could not get something more
cartoonishly insane than this
that's why we're giving away our free
patriotic kids bundle to help your kids
and grandkids learn the truth about
trump and his accomplishments this fun
bundle includes the things i told you
about you get them both for just a
dollar shipping and processing each
the kids guide to president trump is
unbiased
uh and will help your kids learn
everything there is to know from his
election in 2016 and his greatest
accomplishments as an added bonus we're
giving you unlimited access to the great
again restoring faith in america video
and digital work workbook
what's more the special issue of
everbright kids magazine will help your
kids celebrate america and enjoy oodles
just oodles and oodles of great content
and activities to keep them entertained
for hours
oh and by the way it's sort of one of
these subscription grips because look at
this as part of the special offer your
kids can look forward to a new kids
guide covering an important topic for
kids once a month including a streaming
video lesson and workbook all for just
twenty dollars and ninety cents plus
we'll send your kids a new issue of ever
break kids magazine each month for only
five dollars and seventy five cents
oh my god it's a financial grift as much
as it is a political great it's this is
the indoctrination
this is the propaganda they say you know
you send your kids to college they're
gonna get indoctrinated um
you send your kids to school
there might be teachers teaching
critical race theory or there might be
teachers um uh uh
you teaching other stuff but with the
framework of critical race theory
this is the propaganda guys this is the
propaganda the kids guide for patriotic
kids
with the truth about president donald
trump
toe-curling
propaganda toe-curling propaganda
absolutely horrible stuff all right
listen to this
um remember milo yiannopoulos
milo yiannopoulos
was a brit he's still british uh milo
yiannopoulos was a guy
a gay british man
former guest on this program he won't
come on anymore i've invited him to
figure out what's going on with him
won't come on anymore mileanopolis he
became a right-wing darling
his
framing was listen i am
um a
i think he would he was gay catholic and
jewish
i don't know who knows what of this
stuff is even true
and his whole position was
the left can't go after me
as one of these
homophobic
whatever
right-wingers
because i'm gay and catholic and jewish
or you know all the different things
he then um
was
i want to be careful with the language
he then was uh on video
sort of defending i'm not gonna use some
of the words that were used to describe
it because i don't think it was accurate
he was on video
defending
sexual contact
between adults and
what are legally
children
um
and that kind of torpedoed his career
and he disappeared for a while
and then more recently he has kind of
attempted to rehabilitate himself by
saying i am now heterosexual he says
he's no longer gay
and um
yeah make of that what you will and he's
also now i guess i guess a much more
devout catholic that's another part of
it so he's been appearing on like real
america's voice i think and all these
different right-wing places and it just
he's like not really getting traction so
a viewer says david milo is now selling
um
statuettes of the virgin mary
on on like a christian version of the
home shopping network and i said guys
this can't possibly be true it's got to
be some kind of satire it's not
it's not milo yiannopoulos is now
selling virgin mary statues
and other religious paraphernalia on
something called church militant store
just look at this hello and welcome to
the church militant shop my name is
milonopoulos and i'm here with my
co-host deborah vaughan how are you
doing today devon i'm doing okay how are
you i'm well i'm happy because this is
the first of our shows and we're
beginning today with
well probably the most important woman
in history wouldn't you say i think so
she's certainly the most beloved and
we've got today three
items all in celebration reverence of
course of the blessed mother extremely
uh powerful religious items here the
virgin mary we're going to start with um
this wonderful statue which we both own
we do but in different uh medium
different colors that's right you've got
the silver finish yes and i've got this
bronze finish so for the low low price
of 87.50 you can get the adoring virgin
statue
with made from cold cast poly resin in
either bronze or silver perfect for some
kind of strange basement altar or just
keeping on your bedside table if you're
ever having trouble sleeping and need to
look at something that will calm you
down order now
tell us a little bit about the material
this is made from because it's a little
bit special and it looks like a it's
going to weigh a ton and cost 100 to
ship and i want to make sure i have it
right so it's it's a um
cold cast and it's hand painted bronze
color or you can get it in the pewter
sometimes uh one or the other might be
on back order but they come in
um
it's very popular
right um
it i have a shrine at home is this funny
or is it depressing guys is it is it
just depressing that this is what milo
is now doing i have mine in in my shrine
and it looks very very nice
um well i was joking about putting it in
an altar but the woman's literally
saying i have a shrine at home and it
you know it's called the adoring virgin
and i adore her i actually have a rosary
hanging from her i do the same thing do
you do the same thing
one of the nice things about
this particular statue yeah
is the shroud
and on your silver version um something
shows up on the back a little bit more
than on this one this is more of a sort
of uh like a a an age metal finish on
the silver one you get a little bit more
of the detail popping out i think but
i'm just going to say that's a contrast
of color yeah right i'm going to turn
this around and maybe you could explain
to us a little bit about the shroud
so the shroud is oh my god so then they
get into a different i want to find this
other moment they start talking about i
guess now they move into selling a bible
this is a year with mary daily
meditations on the mother of god this is
a very special bible milo has now put
his glasses on for this because it's
very very serious or blind because they
think oh you know just i'm just not sure
what i'm going to get out of it because
some of it you know there's a lot of
historical names this is um selected to
be
endlessly fascinating you know every day
it's a completely different tone and
style and author there's a lot of
swimsuits in alphonsus ligouri but
there's also you know uh louis montfort
pope benedict the 16th all kinds of
different meditations and thoughts on
mary
so i thought i'd read one from a fellow
brit uh the blessed john henry newman so
milo will now read a meditation on the
virgin mary from a bible you can buy for
45 bucks so this british writing always
sounds better i always love to hear you
read well thanks um so i'll just read
you this is day 155 so that they're the
good thing about is they're numbered so
you can start it at any time right you
don't have to wait until january to
start your year with her you can just
you can keep track of yourself thank god
right i mean imagine having to wait
until january to start the readings we
just use a pencil to check them off or
something um so it's called mary vessel
of devotion
and in this the blessed john henry
newman illustrates the meaning of
devotion and shows how our lady
overflowed with devotion to her son
to be devout okay and i'm going to stop
it there because i i i'm trying to i'm
not trying to prevent a cringe stream
today um this is surreal guys this this
is completely and totally surreal and if
you go to the church militant shop you
can get everything from catholic mugs
to um
package deals including prayer books and
various different elements
you can get a catholic me too t-shirt
you can also buy metals even in art deco
style guys what the hell is going on in
this country
or any country for that matter milo
isn't you know he's british um let me
know whether this is sad
funny
or something in between
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
the eggman calling in with a very fair
question about the entire kyle
rittenhouse trial he's he's very much on
point here take a listen to this
how long before kyle rittenhouse is on
the joe rogan podcast getting four hours
to cry his whole story out to america
you think joe rogan is
foaming at the mouth to get him on there
right now chomping it a bit you know he
is
fellow shalom eggman yeah no um
this came up yesterday during our live
stream of the written house uh jury
verdict watch
um i think that so rogan recently had on
i believe her name is amanda knox the
woman accused of killing someone in
italy i believe it was and subsequently
acquitted
and um i think that written house
they're gonna make this kid a hero or a
martyr it's it's a win written house
is
either way he's gonna be lionized either
as a hero or as a martyr as a hero of
self-defense or as a guy who martyred
himself to help people and all this
other stuff and now is you know had to
suffer consequences unfairly one way or
another this guy's going to be a hero
and it would not shock me even a little
bit
to see written house
uh on the rogan podcast telling the
whole story and uh being further held up
as a hero by uh the vast majority um of
the people who hear it we'll keep an eye
on it right i mean it'll depend if he
ends up having to go to prison for a
while it'll be different but we are
standing by for that verdict um the
republican party already has enough safe
seats to win back the house in 2022
through dis redistricting alone this is
a story that is not being told enough
we're going to talk about it on today's
bonus show number two united airlines
after a big big hiatus due to the
pandemic is resuming sales of hard
liquor
this can only go poorly i think
and
we are going to uh talk about bernie
sanders being a no
on the pentagon budget budget vote
778 billion for the pentagon budget
bernie is a no
we will talk about that and more on
today's bonus show
sign up for the bonus show folks don't
miss it don't miss it joinpakman.com is
the place to go
sign up today and we will see you on the
bonus show in near minutes
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman